did she give you any like motherhood
advice
well i got to see her be a mom that's
how i learned to be a mom but my
little nugget
shocked me and she came almost six weeks
early when i wasn't in new york which is
where i live i was in maine yeah i woke
up at four in the morning and i went
into labor and all of a sudden i'm
googling hospitals nearby what and we
made it
i would have been terrified yes i mean i
was but i didn't know what was ahead of
me so it was sort of oh my god the
unknown i didn't know yeah anyway we
made it she arrived like an hour after
we arrived at the hospital and she had
to be in the nicu for the first four
weeks and we were totally unprepared we
thought she was going to come on her due
date so my sister luckily flew to maine
went to target where you can get it all
oh yeah everything i got and by the way
i know what to get i'm like okay yeps to
the aquaphor yes to the
diapers the car seat we had no means of
taking her home from the hospital yes so
i don't know that she gave me advice but
she just stepped up and helped me get
that little nugget through her first few
months of life yeah and her name is cora
georgia coin
georgia after my dad and grandfather so
my dad just calls her
see george
see george it's like she's learning to
read george
george
yeah so she doesn't know what to answer
to yeah um but
all of their grandkids call them
my dad's nickname is jefe which means
the boss in spanish okay which was like
that's self-appointed yeah chosen yeah
exactly
like a little grandchild was like i'm
gonna call you jefe he chose it in
advance and now has taught this yes
basically he was in retirement and
nobody was calling him the boss so he
was yeah so he's like hey you there's a
power struggle within a little bit yeah
i love that
that's a cool name
[Music]
you